deductions in their income is what we're
looking at now these two IDs just like
we've seen before
there's not like two things but they
really really want so net income is the
first thing if the easiest thing to stop
with the idea is that you get paid some
amount right it's like I have this way
at this salary that's what we call gross
income right so net income is what's
left after I've even got like this
what's left after expenses and other
kinds of media you pretty much have to
spend what is left after expenses
I removed from gross income and when
familiar with this some language of
gross and net not just your money but
like you know you buy a can of you know
fish or something like that
cats you know and there's the worse way
which includes the caves to a
substantial in is the net weight which
is the actual fish inside the actual
weight right in the same way net income
is the actual amount of money that you
can actually spend or save you can do
stuff with it as opposed to like gross
income is much too much a lot of that
you will never get access to like you
can tax out of it or it'll be deducted
in other ways there's a whole bunch of
different deductions that reduce your
income and I'll tell you about the the
main ones the big categories and the
first one is superannuation so make sure
this before this is the government's way
of saying yeah we think you're gonna
suck at saving for retirement so we're
gonna force you to write they take a
little slice of money off every time you
get paid and it goes into big pop
something
access until you're at whatever age 65
feet superannuation yeah it's all that
old 65 it comes surprising okay well I
say if you want to refuse your money if
you stop if you have enough money to
stop working early on like they still
give you access to that money home to
new kid since the fact which is why it's
called like superannuation is often
connecting this idea of the age picture
right they're not the same thing but
it's the same idea that we want you to
make sure the wonders of modern medicine
and now that we live for ages and ages
so we need to make sure it's not money
to survive so the gun won't they won't
let you have it yeah now I should I
should say that's a great point to
mention superannuation is a bit of a fun
thing you might have seen ads on TV like
superannuation funds so there's like a
scream lien suit Bob and all these
different people who say yeah we'll look
I feel money with invested for you firm
twenty thirty years if a thing is that
you have to really carefully this when
you guys start working or if you're
already working different employers like
saving a part of Education right they
pretty much all go read it's the first
state suit that's their company they'll
all go there okay but if I would you be
even go to into some other industry or
go work for a private school so has that
then we're super is not going to go to
that company anymore it's going to go to
some other guys so now my buddy is in
two separate places and lots of people
don't ever bother like trying to track
down their money and then they get to
the event like where's where's all my
money gone and it's an enormous terrible
paper trail to follow
okay if someone passes away then access
to that money is gonna plus the native
kid but again because of like crazy
paperwork and where did this money go in
anyway sometimes that money just gets
walleston to the Civic's loop much to
the happiness of superannuation funds
right in fact right now literally I I
noticed some people and what they're
trying to work out is trying to transfer
property into someone else's name
because if it stays in the name of the
person is currently in that person has
no children or dependents nothing like
that so what he's just going to kind of
disappear or my class the next look you
are going very high access it because
it's complicated okay
so that's why I pays to really think
about all these types of things yeah all
right so he said superannuation another
pretty much compulsory cost that we're
all going to have is health insurance
and we're gonna talk about that in
detail in a minute
so health insurance and the other one
that I had was organic that's right
membership fees for things like trade
unions or other institutions which as
part of your trouble you're you're
pretty much required to be part of so
for instance I have to be an
institutional member of the board of
studies of teaching in education
standards but to actually be employable
in each other school I have to be a
member there and that cost me the suite
privilege of being part of that and
working cost me a hundred bucks a year
right every year I have to pay that if I
don't pay it
I can't work it's illegal so therefore
like that's an expense that I'm really
going to be able to use that money in
part of my gross income but it leaves my
hands as soon as I get so that's why it
is not what we call the deductions
now you take ninety gross income put
them in now I'll just quickly show you
if you have a look at 1g in the first
few questions they're all about just
working out what their income is and
like he's a person come and here's some
deductions can use subtract like that's
that's always I'm not gonna do any tight
end
what I want to talk about properly
is something like this now this is
actually really detailed so you probably
want to put this in its own subheading
of health insurance I'm going to do most
of my writing over there because it'll
be easier for me to label stuff a lot of
the maths that's related to stuff like
deductions is not just like what is the
deduction but what do you get for your
production and also excuse me
what like how would you gonna pay for
that and on what basis okay it's a
little bit like when we were working out
wage and salaries and it's kind of like
ah how much per week tell me to forget
how much like annually all that go
so how I look at this table for me
there's a lot of information together
and I want to try and unpack it so I'm
gonna do some lately here but you might
want to put this under your heading of
health insurance so you don't do for
free in your in your text okay first
thing we want to point out you will
notice if you can see this table in
front of you as well the first thing you
want to talk about is on these
adjectives here the top intermediate and
basic okay
so what these refer to if you want to
put a little bit of it right these are
levels of come on okay so basic hospital
Intermediate School on top has talked
about excess in a moment what they are
thirty is look we're going to go in a
hospital without in our lives right what
you're going to go for some things are
very very common very common other
things that are a bit less common and so
it's like well I'm thinking I'm healthy
enough and I'm not gonna have like a
knee operation or like have a hernia
room or something like that so basic
intermediate and top refers to all right
if you go into the hospital what do you
wanna be covered for like are you really
just be covered for all the basic stuff
which is like if I haven't
attack or if I you know I just got
uncontrollable bleeding and I want him
to a pregnancy all these kinds of basic
things which they could happen to anyone
or you might want to pay more costs more
as you go up pay more but that means
when you get into hospital you'll have
to pay less in order to actually get
treated okay so it's like there might be
some really strange like I'm gonna let
me have a you were born with like a clay
logical disorder to look like that and
it's quite uncommon right so what will
happen is you're going to need maybe
need intermediate or top cover in order
to be like I arrived at hospital and I
want a specialist the cardiologist to
have a look at what's going on it's
going to be really expensive right
you can also things like obstetrics and
gynecology they also put on this like oh
am I gonna try out in the next five
years then I want to make sure that I
have the cover that will be when I get
into college there so that's what these
levels of comic cover our top
intermediate and basic and you can see
just have a look here at these parts
here these are the different costs
Turner associates as you go up you know
maybe if you want to get into hospital
and I kept her in private
rule like rather than a board which is
with four other people you're gonna need
to pay more cover for that